la decisión del tribunal constitucional
desató críticas al interior del
parlamento polaco no podemos estar de
acuerdo con acciones ilegales no
aceptaremos el pseudo veredicto del
pseudo tribunal y tenemos un ruego los
médicos sean valientes juraron salvar
vidas y la dignidad de ahora en adelante
la dignidad y la seguridad de las
mujeres están en sus manos y también
tenemos un ruego a las mujeres seamos
solidarias y apoyémonos mutuamente el
tribunal respondió a una querella
presentada hace tres años por un grupo
de parlamentarios del ultraconservador y
nacionalista ley injusticia el partido
que lidera una coalición en polonia con
mayoría absoluta
en las calles miembros de grupos
denominados probidad se libraron el
fallo
[Música]
obtuvimos la confirmación de que la
matanza y selección de niños sospechosos
de efectos genéticos o enfermedades es
incompatible con la constitución polaca
el tribunal lo dictaminó por unanimidad
las reacciones en contra no se hicieron
esperar y cientos de personas que
defienden el derecho al aborto
manifestaron hasta altas horas de la
noche lo que el gobierno nos está
haciendo hoy no solo nos está quitando
nuestros derechos de las mujeres pero
también nuestros derechos humanos por
primera vez podemos decir con seguridad
que en polonia tenemos la peor ley de
aborto en europa una vez que entra en
vigor el fallo el aborto sólo estará
permitido en polonia en caso de
violación incesto o una amenaza para la
salud y la vida de la madre volviendo al
país de tradición católica como el único
de la unión europea
aparte de malta que restringe
severamente el acceso al aborto